each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
started for all the online viewers not
it's my pleasure today to host Ian Smith
and Sonny Consalvo from Intel research
in Seattle they're here to talk about
their social mobile applications and not
only what they've been doing in the area
of privacy but what they intend to do in
the future both of them are senior
researchers I didn't tell a research
Ian's got his PhD at Georgia Tech and
then worked at park for student and
Sonny is currently getting her PhD at
the I school at the University of
Washington so let's welcome them and I'm
looking forward to hear what they have
to say yeah I'm the tall one yeah so I
guess I should go back this talk has
been through a few revisions the city
and Nevada thing you will see a few
mistakes about American geography that I
made when I was naming some projects and
was absolutely convinced about what the
capital of Nevada was and things of that
nature also we have a huge laundry list
here of collaborators and this is not
even complete these are the people that
we felt we couldn't possibly leave off
the slide there are many others at a
variety of institutions intel has its
lab model which I'm not going to bore
you with again but yeah we collaborate
with a lot of people and if you don't
know IRC is until research Cambridge I
expect most of you can expand the rest
of the acronyms so I need to tell you
where this project sort of came from and
we have a project in a lab called place
lab which is a fairly I don't know
fairly big project by our standards
perhaps not by yours but you know with
several people working on it but what
place lab is is a beacon bakes location
system and most of you I'm sure are
probably busily typing on your laptops
right now and it's www place left org
and you can grab all the publications
and that sort of thing there's a sort of
fairly complete paper about place lab
that's about to come out and pervasive
in May but the basic trick is really
really simple wait the way place lab
works it's you know if you know where a
bunch of radio beacons are in the
environment and you know which ones you
can hear you can work out where you are
right and the details of how to do this
or a bit more complicated than that but
you can think of just saying
kind of in between the set of beacons
that I can hear that sort of how place
lab works we work in a ubicomp lab so
place and location are really really
important ideas and you're going to see
them throughout this this talk we're
going to talk a lot about place and
location but it works on a lot of
different kinds of radios so as I said
you know place lab works by this
triangulation scheme and I'm sure most
of you can probably work out in your
head that that's a sensible thing to do
with Wi-Fi we can actually do it on a
variety of different techniques
including GSM cell beacons bluetooth if
does anybody here have a bluetooth
device that doesn't move no okay so
that's not a particularly interesting
thing because there aren't very many but
if you had a bunch of Bluetooth beacons
say scattered around your building we
can do the same trick with Bluetooth
beacons and from a privacy standpoint
which you saw in our title place that is
very careful and at least gives you a
solid base of privacy to work on in the
sense that it calculates everything on
your device so place lab does not
require you to have an infrastructure
provider that knows where you are the
place lab authors including me do not
know where you are when you're using it
it triangulate your location on your
device now as you're going to see in
this talk most of the time what you want
to do with your location is talk to
somebody else about it which will in
fact you know allow you to disclose your
private information but that's your
choice the place lab infrastructure at
least gives you a chance to do things
that our privacy observant because we do
the calculation locally so we're going
to talk a lot about social applications
but there are some other things you can
do locally on the device the simplest
one is the sort of thing that most gps
units are used for which is wayfinding
which is you know i'm here i need to get
somewhere else give me directions you
know an application using place lab or
for that matter gps can actually do this
without talking to anyone you know you
can just listen to the environment and
calculate that sort of information but
most of the things that Sony and I are
interested in are of not of that form
their social applications so in
particular we're interested in social
mobile applications so what's a social
mobile app this is actually one of these
definitions that I always find what's
the social mobile application uh is my
usual answer but sort of historically
every time someone's invented the
communication technology people quickly
adopt it as a social technology so
telephony
email I am I would argue postcards are
social technology i mean i don't know
how many of you actually send postcards
but you know it's always interesting
that the postcards usually say thinking
of you or something on the front or
that's the kind of thing you right but
actually that has nothing to do the
point is so the other person thinks
about you because you're the one on the
beach in the Mediterranean and you want
to make sure they know about it but
anyway that's a different problem as
people get more and more mobile devices
these sort of applications are going
mobile oh I have to go my first prop
here i have this device is my is my
mobile phone I don't know I assume most
of you have probably seen these these
are sidekicks which you can get four
minus fifty dollars on on Amazon at the
moment it's a little tiny devices this
big it has always on I am always on
email and it's pretty small you put it
in your pocket and you're ready to go
right so this is used I'm using these
technologies in a social mobile way
sometimes I don't use them as socially
as I should but that's a different thing
so there's IM the phone gateways how
many of you people know about the love
getty i assume many of you do ok so it
was a little device if you haven't seen
it which was in Japan which you carried
around with you and sort of was a sort
of matchmaker for people who were nearby
there's also applications that are
appearing a specialty in dense
metropolitan areas like social light
which is a way to start up in New York
that does a sort of ability to tap your
friend on the shoulder sort of virtually
when you're not you know when you're not
physically co-present when you're both
moving around also there's an
application called dodgeball which is
very popular of New York apparently went
through quite the rise and fall in San
Francisco recently and anyway it's got
about 15,000 users and it's a way that
you can find out where your friends are
right so in New York this is actually
quite relevant that basically you can
say I'm at CBGB's and the cyst and you
tell the system that it looks up where
all your friends are and tells you when
your friends are nearby so it can sort
of do this sort of physical matchmaking
for people in a mobile world and I have
actually seen this application in use
and it is amazing the way people use it
I mean they move totally dynamically
based on what dodgeball says is going on
I was actually with some dodgeball
people as an example and they were
getting constant streams of information
about what
are people where they were nearby and
they would go from this bar to the next
bar to some music venue to some trivia
place based on sort of this information
they're getting dynamically and almost
all of this is you might argue of know
sort of economic value other than maybe
two bar owners right I mean this is a
social application this is about meeting
your friends on the street so there's
also the opposite side of this which is
solitude so if you think about this this
is interesting that dodgeball actually
offers you the ability to spy on other
people without telling dodgeball where
you are right you can get information
from dodgeball you can actually there's
an explicit way to say i want to get
other people's information without
giving up mine right and interestingly
the reason this was put in besides the
obvious sort of voyeurism is people want
solitude sometimes sometimes they
actually even though they're out in the
world they want to be left alone so
we're going to see throughout our top
that we're going to be talking a lot
about social mobile applications and
sort of its respect for solitude and
privacy and it's it's worth this point
sort of saying that most the time when
we're talking about privacy we mean
other people not knowing your location
most of that is sort of a privacy versus
publicity thing there's also the other
kind of privacy which is solitude which
is the right to be left alone and
interestingly our court system in the
u.s. if you're interested has spent a
lot more time with decisions about
solitude than it has about the other
kind so I just thought I'd random random
legal reference so what have we been
doing it looks like we're doing
something I just sit at my desk all day
and stuff happens I don't actually do
anything but we've done a variety of
different studies and we're going to
talk about these in turn this first
study is what Sonny ran mostly last
summer but starting a little bit before
that with a really terrific grad student
Tara Matthews who has as that already
confirmed so you will all get to meet
Tara she's really really fantastic and
we're only mildly bitter that she's
coming here rather than coming back so
there was a study that we did about
location privacy and about how and what
people want to disclose and to whom we
did another study of application called
Reno that I'll talk about and I brought
some props for that and we did a
pervasive paper about sort of a friendly
deployment with about eight
people then we have just recently
completed a deployment with some people
with Seattle families to try to get at
some more of the sort of privacy and
sort of applications of social mobility
there's currently an application excuse
me and study going on right now about
sort of place discrimination I'll talk
just briefly about that and I'll also
talk a little bit about what our future
work is with fitness and social mobility
and if I get a chance I'll throw in some
gaming stuff because I think that's a
lot of fun this talk is relatively
Gaussian it's much more focused on the
middle so the stuff at the ends here is
going to probably get a little bit less
it's sort of a Gaussian with a with a
very long tail on the front so with that
I believe I'm going to let Sonny go so
as the invention Tara Matthews and I ran
a study over summer and that's what I'm
going to talk about we're going to be
presenting it in all of its glory at Chi
this year actually so he's being modest
is currently up for best paper award at
Chi and that has not been decided just
let me dead and fingers crossed so
anyway let's imagine that at the time in
the not-too-distant future it's 7 p.m.
on a saturday and you get this
interruption on your cell phone from
your boss wanting to know where you are
well how are you going to respond to to
something like that or maybe it's 3 p.m.
on a tuesday you know you're supposed to
be at work but you ducked out to run
some errands how are you going to reply
then so what we know is that
technologies that are going to allow
these things to happen are coming
they're already here with some e 9 11
which is going to allow by end of this
year cell phone providers to be able to
locate your cell phone within about 50
meters in most places and we're also
seeing it with Mo does anyone know what
M mode is sort of M mode so we found
that every time yeah we go to we can
ever figure out the menu system to get
it back but there is a way in fact that
AT&T now singulair offers you to query
someone else's location and if they
choose to respond it usually gives you
the nearest cross streets where they are
depending on the cell tower and coverage
it's more or less accurate it's in
theory popular but I don't know anybody
who's been able to show me navigate
their menu system and last time I try it
I went to the website to figure it out
and the instructions are actually old
they talk about a past menu system so I
can't figure it out but
I have a high bar for design so anyway
well these things are exciting they're
going to come at a cost because while
it's valuable to disclose your location
it can be risky there are times when you
don't want someone else to know where
you are and there are times you don't
want someone else to know that you don't
want them to know where you are so how
are we going to help you manage such a
trade-off well we decided to tackle this
head-on in a formative study over summer
where we wanted to look at using a
variety of techniques to figure out how
this would happen so most of the
previous work we saw was all done on
recall based survey techniques that
happened at a lab or maybe was a survey
passed out by email and what a lot of
people complained about was people
weren't able to make these decisions
because they were out of context we
don't really know how they would want to
respond to things so we decided to
approach it a variety of ways and we
started with some semi-structured
interviews and people did all of these
questionnaires and exercises we had them
build out their social networks for us
so we understood who the players and
their lives were and how important these
people were and what roles they played
and then we're actually able to take
that social network data and use it in
something called experience sampling
method does anyone know what experience
sampling is so we a good a large number
of people so for those of you who don't
essentially what you do is interrupt
people frequently throughout the day and
you ask them questions about what's
going on right now you don't want to ask
too far in the past or else you're going
to introduce recall bias so you're
trying to get as close as you can to how
they would actually respond to something
and it's a technique that came out of
psychology it's often used for drug
withdrawal you know do you want your
heroin now or or something like that and
we're trying to use it for for ubicomp
and building new technologies so what we
were we did was we had some code that
runs on Palm Pilots to do experience
sampling method and we added a way to
introduce variables into the questions
so that we could ask about specific each
participant could be asked about
specific names within their social
network so rather than having to ask
them generic question like what would
you tell a co-worker right now if they
wanted to know your location I could ask
Ian what he would tell me or Anthony and
he might respond to those things
differently so we were able to get at
those those meaningful responses and
then also we followed up about why the
answer the way they did what they wanted
to share so we were able to get a lot of
rich data about how they would respond
in the situation why and what the RAM
were if the system behave differently
than they would have liked and then they
also completed a nightly voicemail diary
for two weeks that told us if they went
anyplace unusual because we were
wondering if where they went if it was
someplace newer exciting did that mean
they were more or less likely to
disclose in this strange place on the
one hand you could say hmm a strange
place it's no harm in giving that out
because you're not going to be there
again so you know how hard is it going
to be for somebody to find you or you
could say people don't you don't want
people to know that you've gone to some
strange place so we didn't know and we
wanted to find out so anyway these all
of this was conducted over a two-week
period that was the experience sampling
method and voicemail diary was over two
weeks and the interviews and exercises
were on either side of that with 16
people in the Seattle area we had even
gender split people were aged 24 to 64
they all regularly use cell phones and
got out of the house with the regular
frequency they all had non technical
careers we specifically screen people
like ourselves out and most were
full-time and several or either married
or in some sort of a serious
relationship which does come into play
later so some of the big results we
found was first of all people were
willing to disclose their location at
some level about seventy seven percent
of the time so of the requests there
were about four thousand or close to
4,000 that the people answered each
participant received ten questions per
day in the ten questionnaires per day
there were several questions /
questionnaire in the experience sampling
method and we had a response rate of
about ninety five percent so we sampled
people throughout the day like if you
were to call me and say where are you I
would say at work right and I've
disclose my location yes is that what
you mean in this context we are not
paying that guy he is not a plan this is
a good question if we'll come back Bob
will address it right now so disclosing
something meant they were willing to
give up something about their location
as opposed to giving up nothing about
their location and something they were
able to choose from a list of what type
of thing they would be able to respond
to and work was one of the things the
actual address of this building was
another thing the city was another thing
they could communicate the zip code so
they had a long list of different types
of granularity
place they would be able to disclose and
yes in many cases you off you wasn't out
of they say I'm here they don't look it
uncle Carol under the god guide the
other end of the phone isn't where they
are right well so that's why we wanted
to make sure we were putting the request
as if it came from a specific person and
we did couch all of the questions in the
Reno application that unions going to
talk about so it was this application
where you could request someone else's
location they would receive it like a
text message on a phone so it wasn't a
verbal prompt it was something that
would show up and you could choose
whether or not to respond to it and then
you could also ask for their locations
so we also said hey whose location would
you want to ask about right now so they
did know the person they knew where the
person lived because it was in a purse a
person who is important to them and yes
they had a variety of choices on how to
respond does that address the sure so
anyway and that's what the fairly
specific less specific in vague were so
fairly specific was like an address or
so specifically was respond via your app
not respond via any channel that was a
bit that's correct with a system you're
responding for the system
and so people were not surprisingly most
likely to share their information with
their spouse or their significant other
they answered yes to ninety-three
percent of the request but as you'll
notice that was not one hundred percent
and so a lot of the reason why was a one
of the young mothers who was in the
study said tonight I don't want my
husband to know when I'm at Baby Gap cuz
he's gonna give me a hard time about
spending money there you know so they
don't or the other guy who said I told
my wife I took the dogs out for exercise
and I didn't do it you know I didn't
want her to know that I was not in fact
doing that so even with the very trusted
people in our lives we don't always want
them to know where we are and there's
always the I told her I left the office
15 minutes ago and I'm still here and so
if I really told her where I was she
would know I in fact had not left the
office so also not surprisingly they
were pretty irritated when they started
getting these requests from their
manager or boss they were only willing
to share about thirty four percent of
the time odds were those times were
during work hours on a weekday and when
those requests came in after hours are
on the weekend people actually cut
pretty irritated we were these were all
hypothetical requests that we just
randomly were generating and people were
really mad in a couple of situations
like that was so inappropriate it was
Saturday it was four and she had no
right to know where I am so people
really got incited about that and so the
granularity of what they shared you know
how detailed the information was
strongly tied to how close the requester
lived to the participant and that was
less about privacy but more about the
fact that if someone lives in Virginia
and I tell them that I'm at 1100
northeast 45th street in Seattle they
don't know what that means but if i say
seattle that means i'm not on vacation
and that's probably what they wanted to
know
so that's the blurring has anyone heard
about blurring as a technique to protect
your privacy and this is disclosing
something true but vague and we did not
find people consciously using this to
protect privacy but we did find that
they were useful things to share so it
is good to have that available to you
like I mentioned a lot of times the more
detailed information is not what the
person is after we had another
participant who was on a road trip that
went from Canada down to California and
so there were times when she responded
Canada and it wasn't because she didn't
want to give up exactly where she was
but she was traveling on the highway and
said well I'm going to be somewhere else
in an hour so what they need to know is
that I'm in the Canada part of the trip
another kind of fun thing we found was
has anyone heard of the Western Harris
privacy segmentation index this
categorizes people into a privacy
fundamentalist pragmatist or unconcerned
so anyway we gave people to the test and
categorize them before they actually
started excuse me we did it at the end
but then we looked at their responses to
see if there was a correlation and how
they would respond based on their
privacy classification we did not see
one and I were not very surprised we
didn't see it in this study because this
was a study about sharing with your
social relations and the survey is
completely based on business and
consumer privacy type issues but in a
different study we ran over summer we
also found no correlation to use of
grocery store loyalty cards and these
categorizations so i dint will have time
at the end but if we do we brought the
survey if anyone cares it's three
questions and you can all find out what
you are if you're interested so
so I think I'll turn it over to ian's
now well we've had enough science will
go back to comedy I guess so we we've
written a paper that's going to appear
at pervasive in Munich in I think these
8th of May or something like that so I
would strongly encourage you if you like
German beer to take in that conference
and it's excellent accommodations so
well I should I should probably go back
we should ask you know Reno is actually
where the horrible mistake about
geography was made you know the capital
of Nevada and I was absolutely sure the
capital Nevada was not Las Vegas and
everything it ends held by the way if
you don't know I assume you guys
probably know this is usually named
after places because it's actually
easier from a sort of marketing for
various marketing and legal reasons
naming things after places is a good
idea so we do this with many of our
projects and I didn't want to do las
vegas and i wanted to do the capital of
Nevada which I got a terribly dry
everything wrong what they have carson
city yesin city and we had to do a
sequel sequel project just so we would
have a project named after the capital
in the bottom but it's a social mobile
application that Sonny had done the
formative work on in the summer and and
we decided we were going to try to build
this thing and do it in a reasonable way
but we had to have some principles for
how we were going to do it one thing is
we wanted to do it on a device that was
really ubiquitous despite the fact that
i work for Intel and Intel is very very
happy with laptops laptops are not
ubiquitous people do not carry them
absolutely everywhere we're desperately
trying to make harnesses that you could
wear your laptop with but we're not
quite done with that yet the device
should position itself we're gonna be
talking a lot about location and if you
remember back to my intro talking about
place lab we want the device to position
itself we want the device to know where
it is and we're going to talk about that
there's a lot of ways you could do that
you can do that with a GPS I don't know
how many of you seen the GPS phones are
pretty popular in Japan there's also a
GPS which is sort of a fast locking
version of GPS which has a couple of
additional benefits most notably that
like when you walk out of a building it
tends to get the lock with satellites
much quicker you can do that from sunny
study we learn that people design their
responses for the other person so I'll
use this this guy's terrific question
you know people often want to say
symbolic names they don't want 1,100
northeast 45th street they want work
they want home they don't want 2600
second Avenue many people that they
communicate with would find it fairly
useless if i gave you 1,100 northeast
45th but if i say work you would go okay
I kind of know where that is or
something like that so we wanted to use
place instead of location and we
certainly didn't want to make the
privacy situation any worse as I said we
wanted to do things on mobile phones
because those are really ubiquitous
devices but you know for those of you
that don't know you know gsm phones can
be tracked via that the cell network so
are sort of harm here our sort of model
here was Google esque if that's actually
an adjective which is you know do no
evil right don't make the world any
worse in terms of the way the
application works so for example one of
the design things that this led to is
our applications actually implemented
peer-to-peer there's no central service
that actually tracks where everybody
who's using our application works it's
totally done by the phones and they talk
to each other so that that's sort of
trying to make the world note no worse
so this is a picture I have a few of
these phones over here they're big
they're big I think it's these are these
are the phones that this runs on which
are these are nokia 6600 there they're
pretty reasonable little platforms
they're not you know the best thing
since sliced bread they're not
terrifically well powered but they're
reasonable things for people to carry
around what are the key things that Reno
can do you can ask someone else where
they are you could tell someone where
you are you can do this either prompted
or unprompted when someone else asks you
where you can just tell them we threw
some automatic things in there too
because the phone knows where it is we
can build something called a waypoint
which is whenever I get home tell my
wife that's an automatic thing which we
call it we originally called the trigger
but later the Waypoint word was a little
more satisfying you can also put someone
kind of on your buddy list and then
whenever they ask you you don't have to
interact with the phone the phone will
calculate its best guess of where you
are and send it back without any
interaction so the idea is with that if
you have someone that you trust they can
query your phone and we'll talk a little
bit about that in a bit in particular
that we had an audit trail that we put
in place so that you would know what
your phone was doing automatically even
if you didn't interact with it
we also have sort of an inbox sort of
model because I can never get away from
doing email research which is the sort
of thing that it's like the SMS inbox
that's sort of the location in box that
says what who was asking you for what
and what you've told them and then as
you're going to see we're going to have
this one nastiness which is teach which
is you know you have to tell the phone
where the name of the place the first
time you go there then there as we're
going to see this is going to have a
dramatic and somewhat unfortunate effect
a little later so to give you an idea
this is actually looking at your
location in box here this is these names
have all been anonymized and you know
I've been told this is from friends and
I don't watch brands everybody goes no
but that could never happen wouldn't
Ross be telling feet no anyway so I
don't know what these names are any good
from the standpoint of friends but
here's a case where Ross is disclosing
his location and yes this is really ugly
because this is the shall we say the set
of tools that we got from Nokia to build
the UI but this is a disclosure from
Ross if you just if you click on that it
will give you some more details but this
is basically Ross tells you is a total
fitness gym and this is a query from
Phoebe to you asking you where you are
and yes we try to get more information
crammed on there and no you can't do it
it's really hard with milk use default
UI but this is an example where you want
to tell someone else where you are and
what the system does is it computes sort
of the nearby places and it uses the
cellular network and sort of a variant
of triangulation it's actually based on
some ideas from John crumbs work i'm
sure most of you know him basically it
gives you a list of places that are sort
of nearby and to give you an idea i have
some graphs that i can bore you with but
the upshot of it is that you know with
sort of a hundred meters separation
between the places we do extremely well
when you start going below 100 meters we
give you lists that look like this
because we don't know which of these
places you're actually at we can't get
that fine grain so this is going to be
great when you're want to do the
different you want to tell someone
you're home because home is probably
pretty well separated from other places
that you go at least if you don't live
where I do and you just click on it so
note that this does this takes away the
tightening step if you think about this
as a front-end to SMS which is what it
is then this just takes away the typing
part
you can now ask somebody with a couple
of clicks and you can tell somebody else
where you are with a couple of clicks
and no typing on the phone is required
this is the phone composition so so yeah
these by the way the people who were
getting too thanks here are the
undergrads who helped us on this project
and to describe them after this project
was one of my coworkers describe one of
them as bleeding from the ears when this
subject was when this study was done so
they work extremely hard um doing a
pilot study usually you do a pilot study
because you don't really know what
you're doing so some things you know
happened we had eight users for five
days which was a Wednesday to us on it
included a weekend we did some pre study
questionnaires we asked them to fill out
email Diaries every day we had enormous
logs that were kept on the phones of all
their activities they were members the
research team and their families we have
this terrific little graph here which
shows you in there in my color scheme
how these people were connected to each
other one of the reasons to do this
pilot on people who are members of the
research team is what if things go
horribly horribly wrong now we're
actually disclosing to both the system
and other people fairly private
information you know about location you
can imagine that bugs in the software or
of design flaws cause automatic
disclosures of locations that are bad so
we felt that court of eating our own dog
food was sort of the best thing to do in
the short term we did a leather
experiment later we gave everybody nokia
6600 s which were the phones that you
just saw and we loaded them with their
sim cards so they kept their phone
number two had to carry a different
device and this is kind of a mixed
blessing as Sonny points out for some
people these phones are too big and
there were people who complained about
that the other interesting thing we got
was if you don't know Nokia's new keys
are all software all the way down so if
you do while one semicolon the phones
phone functionality will lock up it is
not memory protected it does not have
anything it will just if you have a bug
in your software you can disable the
phone and do you know there are some
others with some small children who said
you know I depend on this phone this
cannot fail so one of the things that we
learn is you know the expectations about
software that runs on a phone are
substantially higher than you might
normally expect with sort of research
software
so just to give you an idea what
happened in the in the pilot this is
total disclosures by participant with
our people we had interest varying from
quite substantial to almost none with
our pilot people the interesting thing
about these giant bars is not that these
people were the most excited about the
application what this says is more or
less they defined waypoints or triggers
for places that they went frequently in
other words you might argue they were
able to predict a little bit about where
they go and when the system had an
automatic trigger for their it detected
it does that make sense so that's that's
not that this person was the most
interested but rather they you might say
did the best job of sort of enabling the
system do things automatically here's
who was it also the automatically
replied to somebody uh this version of
the software did not have the automatic
replies that was the second version side
simplifies my slice yeah I'm sorry gonna
have to kill you later for exposing that
flow um anyway so what did we learn so
I'm sorry I only do comedy so one of the
things that what you think about is the
1960s James Bond films they're all
pretty much the same it doesn't matter
which one you think of and almost always
bond is in MS office and he's getting
dressed down for some transgression or
another it's not particularly important
which one and what happens Miss
Moneypenny opens up the door that you
always see this big heavy wooden door
she open the door and what does she say
who's a good bond expert what does Miss
Moneypenny interrupt this conversation
to say well she doesn't she says various
things but there's one that's pretty
common anybody one guess
okay you guys all watch these kind of
highbrow films I'm sorry I'm know I'm
embarrassed um here's the deal she often
says it's london calling for you sir
that's a common one why did she say that
I mean London even the 1960s has 10
million people in it that's not
particularly useful you'd think but yeah
that's what she says that's what you
understand as the viewer to mean holy
crap somebody important from governments
call it may be the prime minister right
but what did you get that from you got
it from the symbol saying if london
calling for you sir a clever observer
might also realize that she interrupted
a meeting to disclose this information
so she did something quite active so
what we're going to see in these results
that we learned quite quickly is that
place is kind of a proxy for lots of
stuff when people share contacts like
the viewer watching a James Bond film
you can get a lot of stuff from place
right and Miss Moneypenny is is an
example here of this kind of behavior
where you tell somebody some place and
what you really mean is remember all
that other stuff we'd always talk about
well this is sort of a marker for that
okay so Miss Moneypenny does this and I
would also point out that Miss
Moneypenny also doesn't say it's you
know 112 old grocery in replace office
47 she doesn't say that either she's not
saying an exact address she is saying a
really general vague thing and yet you
get the value out of it so when people
have shared context location turns out
to be really really helpful here's an
example what from one of our subject
about basically another subject told fi
believe hear it in though this is this
is actually G gets told by F I'm at
sea-tac airport at ten o'clock at night
now an amazing thing was able to be
happened but G because they knew the
contacts was able to discover oh yeah I
remember we talked they're getting
visitors and we want to get together
with the visitors now note that was an
active thing was done at ten o'clock at
night on a Thursday which is not typical
but all it said was SeaTac Airport so
this is sort of an example of the kind
of way people use place to use it as a
proxy for for context and all kinds of
amazing things these sort of amazing
leaps were surprisingly common you know
from seatac airport to I want to get
together with the people who
isn't it do we have the merchant mix
example um don't know if we have that
here should we should we tell that story
you think it's but it's that place can
also be misinterpreted so we had the
idea where one of the participants
disclosed to his spouse that he was at
merchant mix and it turns out that
there's a bus stop right in front of
merchant mix and so he was trying to
tell her I'm on my way home now and she
happens to like a certain dessert that
merchant mix has and she interpreted
that as I'm going to stop off and get
you some dessert before I come home now
and so he showed up without dessert and
hilarity did not ensue um cut out yeah
so yeah this is this is actually but the
point is that carries a lot of context
whether or not it's correctly
interpreted so automatic disclosures
were two edged sword we had some mixed
reactions I don't want to go into a lot
of the technical details of this but we
got the 12-time wrong be honest with you
we had too many false positives people
were driving by a place that they had a
trigger set for and the phone would sort
of decide that it was at the place and
then would send something so we had too
many false positive we got the dwell
time wrong but there's manual disclosure
has this beautiful property there's
human beings with big brains on each end
right and people quickly learn that when
someone goes to the trouble to tell me
like Miss Moneypenny coming in the
office it's more important that when the
phone which may or may not be correct
telling me something automatically
people quickly learn this but this is
actually an example where a participant
sort of decided that they wrote the
trigger in one context and it got
interpreted in another the person
basically is saying you know it was okay
for some colleague of mine to know when
I got home from work because that's sort
of what I meant when I put a trigger on
my house but yet it has this other thing
which is you know I went out what is
this I was out running an errand and
returned to the house and I wasn't
comfortable with the colleague knowing
that so all night disclosure is really
tricky thing to get right and I think
you're going to see in the later study
that you could make an argument that it
should just be done away with just a
quick clarification so everyone in the
system
not a fighter where they oxidizes know
they personalize it in you we did this
actually just as an interesting for
processing us we actually asked
everybody for their their preferred list
of triggers at the before the study and
then we coded them all into the phones
they were not changeable during the
study during this part of the study and
as you'll see the second study we allow
people to change it and they didn't so
we tried real because you know we're not
real people in our labs so we had some
actual humans that we recruited by the
second one and this was led by a
terrific grad student of Giovanni hlo
from Georgia Tech who who did an
absolutely amazing job so I'm gonna
claim all the credit here because he's
not here today so we wanted to know if
you do this with real people what
happens you know what are the social one
of the privacy issues in this kind of
social mobile application in a
particular what helps them manage their
location privacy is it buddy list is it
the fact that there's a specific set of
people that I know and trust that helps
me manage my privacy and how is
plausible deniability manifested so I
don't know if you've seen the data but
orange I believe the mobile phone
company in Europe did a did a study that
says that twenty percent of the time
people do not tell the truth when asked
where they are in a mobile phone okay
they also don't answer phones Oh sort of
my phone's off I didn't get your message
you know I'm sure you've all heard this
one and probably said it yourself right
plausible deniability is a really
important sort of social slack that is
really important to today's society and
we wanted to know you know will people
mislead other people about their
location because our application would
actually allow you to do this you could
in fact say something other than where
you were so um we deployed it to two
families in the Seattle area after
enormous amounts of gnashing of teeth
and difficulty in recruiting and God
knows what all else basically for
parents for children we tried to get one
friend of each of the children who was
not in the same families in other words
we'd have sort of both horizontal and
vertical power relationships was the
intent we only succeeded with three of
the four children we wanted to create
some privacy tension you would like to
believe that everyone's children are
little angels but in reality many
teenagers are not totally truthful with
their parents
I know that will come as a shock but
yeah so they were between 14 and 17 14
and 17 and the interesting thing was
that initially what we really wanted was
the two families to actually know each
other because we hope that that would
also create some tension and in fact we
had a lot of trouble with recruiting to
actually get that so they turned out the
two families the kids go to the same
school but the two families really don't
know each other very well um you know I
think it's only fair to claim that in
two weeks you don't get around to much
of the novelty effects I'd like to say
we did but I'm sure if Nokia did this
study they could do it for a year five
people accepted a new phone and number
the interesting thing that that is this
is also a class of soporific
expectations they just a lot of people
are really scared of losing anything
about their cell phone for example if we
gave them their old a new phone they
were worried that they wouldn't know how
to operate it especially in a crucial
situation we had people whose businesses
actually dependent on this phone working
properly so some of them accepted a new
phone number we also had up to the kids
I believe two of the kids who were
mobile phone users but did not own their
own in other words they knew how to use
a mobile phone maybe sometimes borrowed
one but they didn't actually own one so
we gave them and they were pretty
excited yeah it was good I was gonna say
and we did this right before Christmas
and I'm thinking those parents hate us
now but anyway a lot of people use their
existing phones we stuffed all their
contacts on to the SIM cards so that
they would get their contact lists nine
of them had the phone still the to the
kids it didn't so the technical
challenge is uptime uptime uptime it has
to work I mean if you're writing
software you just can't they can't have
anything go wrong with mobile phone
expectations about mobile phones are
shocking the idea of rebooting a mobile
phone people go you can reboot a mobile
phone you know another thing was kind of
interesting is that there are
expectations about these phones are such
that they don't actually have a mental
model that includes getting new software
from mobile phone that maybe your people
with let's sort of Microsoft smartphone
type things but a lot of people in the
world don't think of them as things you
could get new stuff for that idea just
is quite alien they also only like to
charge them every two or three days yeah
and are we being bothered up we burned a
battery at a faster rate because our
application wasn't very good
SMS is not always reliable which would
be beyond the scope of what you could do
in software didn't were you able to
measure that at all or how much that
measuring SMS rely on reliability is not
very hard because it happens all right
so like you could have the compared to
two logs from two devices where one
person queried another but the other
person didn't get it we are the process
of drawing those graphs right now we're
actually drawing a directed graph that
shows all the people and all the
messages exchanged they're grinding
those numbers I don't have it for you
right now so how did the application
know the phone location you know I told
you this great story at the beginning
that place lab triangulate the location
it's all great well this has this one
horrible flaw which is place that
requires you know where the cell towers
are right you can't do triangulation you
don't know where the cell towers are and
we had this risk that people would go
places in our study that were important
to them that we didn't have the data
form and while we have pretty good maps
of Seattle we don't want to be a
situation where our study is being
compromised because the absolutely
crucial place to this teenager is not
where we have the maps of the location
so we actually adapted an algorithm from
a pervasive 04 by a guy called les own
and who's a thin which basically is a
signature based scheme so effectively
what it does is when you see a set of
cells you can sort of name it as I'm at
microsoft research right now and the
phone goes well the set of cells that
I've seen recently is kind of this set
so I'll sort of say that microsoft
research and it turns out if you do this
a little bit cleverly we can actually
quite accurately we actually had
literally no problems with the phones
being wrong the phones being wrong when
you do this kind of scheme is not bad
then with some other problems but the
phone's being wrong we're not one of
them so what do we do in terms of data
we did two interviews per participant
one at the mid week between the two
weeks one at the end we also had a
training session for each of the
participants in groups we had four
different interviewers we did email
Diaries every other day which is sort of
every two days we were asking them
questions about their use of the system
and those kind of things that was
surprisingly uninformative I have to
report the also the phones are sent us
email every 24 hours and this was
actually really hopefully measuring our
up time so we would know you know is the
phone actually crashing in some way so
we went out we actually have
quite good graphs of that kind of thing
but we know how many queries people send
to all this kind of stuff so we were
getting summary data every 24 hours
about how people were using the system
which would really help us when we go
into an interview because we would say
you know I can see that you asked so and
so on this date you know because we had
that information by the time they came
to the office yeah and so we I got to
ask fairly detailed questions about
actual events which do not require
speculation so we actually had the real
events logged so this is just some basic
usage information yeah this is actually
sort of weirdly normalized because the
people did not do the study over exactly
the same period so this is sort of
numbering the wait no this is the other
graph sorry this is the one by
participant number so this is how many
notifications they sent and how many
requests they sent I don't know my can I
can I can I say who the participants I
guess I can the participants I'm not
gonna say who they are i'm trying to say
if they're rotatably team versus para sa
your parents so so these two big ones
here are actually parents engaging in a
behavior that i'll talk about this is
actually basically querying the teens
for their location is the typical thing
that's going on here sorry that's the
big the big queries are notification
sent is also the parent i think trying
to feel like they're not being quite as
invasive as they are it's my opinion
just clear both the receiver and
requester so everybody involved in this
had to have your app installed right so
if i wanted to do any location
integration with people who didn't have
your phone your app that would not work
is that correct that is not correct but
sadly true the reality is we built the
application using SMS and we actually
told them that it's human readable so we
actually would allow them to do this
with other people and we even built a
way that someone who didn't have the
application could hit your phone and
cause it to run into our application
which is actually the SMS little text
message thing why wa why ? which is
where are you typically that people use
and and we allowed that nobody used it
so the reality is they only did it with
people in the study I don't actually
know why that is we went to a lot of
trouble to tell them about you could use
it with other people they didn't do it
it was two weeks before Christmas that
could have had something to do with it
and you can make a lot of arguments but
I really thought they would I thought
they would get in
interested in the idea of location sort
of being communicated and they didn't
and I think I've I can speculate about
why that might be but we add interest
that varied from none to to
significantly interested the interesting
result that probably none of you would
have guessed least certainly I wouldn't
have guessed is the teens are less
interested than you think and you know
people think of teens mobile phones oh
it's going to be a huge smash with the
teens the parents are not going to give
a damn and actually was quite the
reverse one of the speculations about
about teens and why they're not
interested is because you know what they
already are very facile of mobile phones
they already know how to use SMS almost
all know all the participants of the
teens now I do now to all knew how to
use SMS so what we're offering them is
basically a shorthand for type and
location queries so they didn't offer
them in my opinion as much value as the
parents who knew about SMS but didn't
how to use it so we offer them a
significant leg up that they weren't
getting otherwise that's my argument I
don't actually have the proof completely
worked out for that we're working on the
numbers right now coordination is the
main driver for use I was terrified by
these people's lives I cannot believe
that the stuff these kids are doing I
mean I don't know what my memory is that
bad but I really had a lot of free time
on my hands when I was a you know
teenager I was shocked at the number of
times where yeah I need to pick you up
here so could we coordinate to make sure
that you're going to be right here so
why I pick you up and I can take you
somewhere else and pick up the other kit
I mean it was it was shocking they all
played soccer they all had like the next
club and you different there are things
they had to do after school and so
basically one of the interesting thing
is the kids need this information they
actually want the parents frequently to
know where they are quite truthfully
because they need the parents are
picking up and take them somewhere else
right there's a huge incentive for them
to be truthful people want to send a lot
more than location the application gave
them the ability to send location they
want to send a bunch of other stuff and
we'll talk a little bout what the
implication that is they also don't have
that many significant places oh the
places they needed to communicate we're
surprisingly small in number I'm
actually going to argue that that number
that we saw here is actually a little
low because i think the data entry on
the phone
sort of name a new place is a sort of
significant bar but still you know if
this number is not huge and it might be
off by a factor of two but it's not off
by a factor of 20 right i mean they
don't need to have an enormous number of
places define so you could almost ask
yourself why even bother doing location
sensing if they only need six or seven
places just put up a list I mean why why
have the phone do all this work to
actually sense the location we're
working on a paper for you become so
this is this is just thoughts not
conclusions surprisingly privacy wasn't
as big of a deal as we thought one of
the reasons as I mentioned is the kids
really do want to be truthful
surprisingly often because they need
that they need the parents to chuck to
shuttle them around we were actually a
little too careful i think i think we
actually did maybe too good of a job of
designing the application to be privacy
sensitive so for example all the
automatic features are off by default
you have to turn lawn oui oui prompted
them to we explained it to them we gave
them documents we asked them we asked
them to do questionnaires they they
didn't use that very much the other
thing is that it only discloses places
you name so sort of trick one of doing
private information is just don't name
places to Reno that you don't want
someone else to know about your pretty
well set right which is a beautiful
privacy enhancing feature but doesn't
give us studies where people are being
dishonest each other because they just
simply don't put them in foil into each
phone bill you need a name yeah that
that is the subject of intense thought
right now about how to do sharing place
name sharing is a lot trickier and
deeper issue than you think it is Oh at
least then I thought it was weird if you
think it is but in the first study home
you couldn't throw around the name home
unless you knew who it was coming from
right or you know it so what we used was
ian's home sony's home right so we
actually did do a little bit of work but
the reality is that this place sharing
is that a lot more tricky I think then
you then I thought it was um
could could a name the gift only one
location without calling ten people did
so can you call it home home as well as
you say we got three pubs yeah that's
cool yeah and we laugh your name is what
you wanted we didn't do any
interpretation of the strings all we
said was this set of cells has this
string binding so we actually had people
as an interesting aside who gave a place
multiple names because what they wanted
was to express what they were doing in
that place so they had a name called
making a sandwich and it had another
name called home because they wanted to
be able to say eating lunch or something
like that making lunch was it making
lunch so they actually interestingly
they didn't understand sort of the cell
power algorithm because obviously making
lunch is really not a terrific choice
from the standpoint of that but anyway
the point stories people did want to
give the place of vocal names and i
think we were actually so concerned
people's privacy that we didn't find a
lot of tension i think i think that's
actually a success disaster you might
argue because i would love to have had
all these terrific examples where kids
were trying to say to one thing to the
parents and then that you know other
kids you know we didn't find a whole lot
of use for automatic features the people
want to be in control there were some
concerns about power issues we did have
a one a kid only one interestingly who
even mentioned the sort of power
relationship with the parents and the
parents forcing him to do something or
other also people don't get that many
messages even three or four times a day
I mean our system was used on average
about two to three times a day poor
participant which you might argue is a
pretty good success right there using
our tool they like it but that's not so
much that it's a management burden you
know until you get to 20 30 messages a
day you don't need automatic stuff you
can handle it so I think the automatic
features I think or the jury is at least
allow maybe not used also as you would
expect they don't use auditing despite
the fact that we gave it to them they
never looked at it that's typical
security literature Hewlett so I want to
get back to it so the automatic features
are not used how what is the Delta that
your feature set is providing versus you
call me and say where or you SMS to me
and say where are you yeah i just type
back at work right or at home or at the
pub so so I'm trying to figure out
because I think your comment about the
teenagers is an interesting when I'm
trying to figure out what was the Delta
terms of functionality they were gaining
weight so you could make an argument
which would not be terrifically bad that
this is a really big acceleration for
typing on the phone that's it it's just
that's a mess with a fancy front end
that lets you type a lot faster it
actually has a couple of other side
effects that we did see in the study one
of them is people use Reno as a sort of
lighter version the kids believe it or
not use their phones in school when
they're not supposed to so they actually
did admit that they liked Reno because
it was quick and did not ring the phone
on the other end because they assume
that the person that rent would have it
in for salomon and we had in all of the
studies people have talked about times
when you would not bother to call
somebody because you didn't want to have
to engage their attention like that but
you did want to communicate something
particularly with okayness checking you
know I got there ok right or where are
you you know right and they could do
that in this lightweight way where they
would not have actually made the phone
call and actually the email diaries and
the interview specifically asked was
there a time when you use this when you
would have made a phone call if you
hadn't had the feature and so the
interesting thing is that may be so my
next slide hang on once again i'm going
to add your delta feature said is on my
next slide oops no it's not the upshot
of it is that you know this is a fancy
front-end to SMS that if you were smart
you would just shove into the SMS system
and then once you get this idea of sort
of having these sort of tools well why
not give them more stuff like talk about
ETA rather than sort of using place in
this sort of indirect proxy kind of way
why not just give them what they want
equities askew activity was huge about
half of our discloses we actually didn't
mention this give them the option to
disclose an activity instead of a place
at about half the time they chose to use
activity I mean again these are all
because they they don't want their using
this as a proxy or something else and I
think if you're smart you just make SMS
have a bunch of these sort of can set
ups you know where certain people ask
you a certain kind of question it's okay
for the system just pop up a menu and
hit me you know two clicks the
interesting thing is the typing is just
a huge huge put off people just really
hate t9 or multi-tap they just really
hate it and the idea of doing it quickly
with in our case about two clicks on the
little button was significantly or
something did you see much group
communication was always one of 10 so no
we didn't and the interesting thing is
because we made a privacy decision that
it was peer-to-peer and we didn't give
them the option to sort of tell multiple
people things we did something kind of
fun with one of the parents who was
asking when she couldn't get in touch
with her daughter she would query the
friend who the daughter was often with
so that daughter actually had a
surprising number of Reese I mean the
friend had a surprising number of
responses to her friend's mother yeah we
didn't build a repeater though which is
probably would have been smart in some
way you know some kind of place where
they could have them and maintain a list
of people to have friends and family and
sort of have the ability to broadcast
you could just enter multiple telephones
oh no cuz it was it was really intended
to be quick and we should have also had
groups on the phones um but Allah oh
well it's right there any 20 so yeah it
someplace that if you were thinking
about this is a chronic presonus did you
probably not see all the interesting
uses that they would have used oh yeah
yeah i think that they had plenty of
uses that they hinted out that we didn't
care we were so focused on location of
privacy but i think it's one of those
things that you feel dumb in retrospect
but don't why didn't we give them some
of the things they were using location
as a proxy for we got a little bit of
activity in the first study that Tara
and I did which is why there was some of
it at all in there in fact the most
popular way to deny your request was
saying I am busy yeah interesting thing
about that is people viewed Reno I think
significantly as a entree to some
further communication they've you asking
people their location which I have to
say was sort of surprising to me I sort
of thought there'd be lots of tape cases
where you didn't need anything other
than this sort of ability to communicate
this way the people viewed it as a you
know is this a time to engage you is it
okay for me to call you that kind of
thing we certainly saw that in some of
our qualitative work yeah and obviously
vary from people who may be driving is
what is your velocity
yeah which we can actually calculate
goes if he's all over the over 55 mph
probably would not a good time to talk
well the interesting thing about that is
that the one of the few cases the units
units of someone being a little bit
deceptive was someone who actually
wanted to say in the car when they
weren't quite in the car yet because
they want to be intent was the other
person to get the idea to get ready
right so that was one of the few cases
where the deception and that's a pretty
weak form of deception was really just a
utilitarian thing say I'm in the car so
that the other person will get ready for
me to pick them up because I'm not quite
in the car yet so if you done that with
velocity you would have bought it you
would have lost yeah I don't know if you
mentioned that um caller ID helps me
when I pick up the phone to kind of get
into the conversation faster because
even before I pick up the phone and of
wood is and somehow it kind of gets the
communication start faster if you
thought about coupling this with caller
ID kind of at the moment I pick up the
phone that I know who it is where the
person is kind of and for various
reasons from like ice breaking to hey I
see you are there and there or you know
stuff like that yeah because I mean
often if I told somebody that that
probably in many cases might indicate
that I want to share something with this
person and then it probably often also
wouldn't mind sharing my location with
it yeah I think it's certainly clear
that that sort of functionality is
something that's desirable it's a bit
tricky to get right I don't know if
you've seen the studies about caller ID
when it was first brought out in the US
but there's actually quite a few details
of that that have to be done really
carefully the studies of caller ID in
the u.s. found varying levels of use for
example between bye-bye number by
household or by line caller Ids when
they were trying think about how to
bring out the feature they didn't know
did you want to do it on a per target
basis of your call did you want to do it
on a per line like what this phone in
the house always discloses its location
but some other one doesn't did you want
to do it on a per call basis so in fact
if you don't get that right i think
people will actually not you i think
people won't like it and the whole
caller ID blocking and the sort of arms
race of caller ID is an example that you
have to get it right so yes we thought
about it and i think it's well I don't
know how to do it right now I know it
needs to be done I don't know how to do
it right
were there other cases where location
was sort of proxy for social context
like the you know who is my daughter
with I mean I'm wit you think those are
features that people would want Who am I
around or who's together and I'm not
there I think the teenager would and are
there kind of unique privacy issues
there well I was going to say one of the
things that you might argue bluetooth is
not useful for too much but one of the
things that's really good for is person
detection because people have unique
mobile phone IDs that would actually in
some reasonable proximity tell you kind
of foods around so it's clear that that
seems like an obvious thing for us to
sort of play around with which is sort
of people detection in remote locations
and it's interesting that the teenagers
didn't mention too many ideas about sort
of hiding stuff from the parents but
that is certainly one that they did
mention I think I'm right I could think
of one case where certainly that we
didn't hear too much about them
deceiving but the sort of idea that I
might be somewhere that I'm telling the
truth about where I am but I'm not
telling the truth about who I'm with is
sort of an interesting question about
retention and sort of managing privacy
let me just throw these slides up and I
will open the floor up to questions this
is um this is some new work we're doing
about sort of the sort of notion of
place and sort of what is a place so
we're doing some work on this right now
we're doing a sunny and I are doing some
user study work and Jeff high towers
doing a fantastic job of sort of you
know how do you decide I mean the phones
for example that one place lab can sort
of tell you a latitude and longitude and
under what circumstances is that useful
and how would one decide that you're at
Barnes & Noble or how would you decide
you're at the starbucks that's inside
barnes and noble which is inside a mall
or is you tillage actually what you want
to say so so the idea of sort of the
technical side of how do you decide what
the name of the place is in some kind of
pseudo automatic way i think is a really
fun topic that we're currently working
on in Jeff Jeff is leading this effort
it's I can talk about it people want but
I should open the floor to question
since we're already I believe 47 seconds
too late
like a very high level question like
just 10,000 foot perspective on the
whole topic could it be that we just lie
more often than we actually think that
we do I mean if you give if I ask you
you know do you lie I don't know it's
yep sure you know like yes I think would
it be that okay just the underlying
phenomenon could it be that we have very
different notions about what we mean
with lying and you know it that we're
much more sensitive to win other people
to give us you know no you know like
when they kind of tell us about the
location but the hanging out and stuff
like that well we may be for ourselves
feel like it's okay to stretch the truth
a little bit and you know we have used
different terms events but I mean we
probably all I is it when we're killing
yeah we exactly we have a reason why
we're doing it and no another cases we
might not understand what that reason is
this is best buddy in the social
psychology literature for some years is
that a fair statement so this is a topic
of enormous death that I Frank we don't
know that much about but I'm gonna
speculate anyway one thing that also you
have to be a little careful of what
studies that we I should have mentioned
this caveat the studies that we've all
done have been self-report so there's
some idea that if you're willing to
deceive your spouse you're almost
certainly willing to deceive some bunch
of bozos at our Intel research that
seems very clear secondly and I think
more dangerously for our family study is
you know what kind of family volunteers
the whole family to participate in a
mobile phone thing at some scientific
research lab about sharing location is
that the kind of family is going to have
a lot of power issues or sort of
unresolved things at home you know so
you sort of have to you know I mean I
think our results are pretty good for
what they are but you have to sort of
take that as a thing and we only really
had one kid who was a friend of one of
the people and he wouldn't have
participated would not anticipate his
parents have been there so so really I
think there's some sort of idea that
sort of well-adjusted people are like
kind of the subjects that tend to
volunteer for Intel research studies so
I think we're all studied so on the on
the other hand I mean you know those
were also people who buy technology so
you might argue our results are
perfectly fine for those people so but
it
a little bit tricky to sort of get at
what people under what circumstances
people lie and under what circumstances
you can admit you can actually measure
it the measuring of lying is is well
known to be very very hard very pretty
interesting to see a little bit more
about just a questionnaire but lying you
know when do you lie I mean this is a
kind of three studies of this Lee when I
was an option in our initial study you
could reply with a lie yeah oh no no I'm
just saying like an overall it looks
like in a way these systems make it
harder for people to lie in some cases
and takes away this opportunity to kind
of do that it would be just general
thought would be super interesting to
hear you know hall just like before you
go in and kind of make it hard for
people to lie just learn more about why
it's important for these people what
does it mean for people to be able to
lie what what rollers are playing their
lives you know what what what do they
get out of it and what what gets away if
they stop having this right and Giovanni
Giovanni kinda went into this study kind
of hoping to find that I mean Giovanni
has done the sort of digging on the sort
of social psychology literature in we
were able to tell if they responded with
something that was not at the time to
decide just to flip yeah so we actually
had phones actually logged any case
where they responded with the answer
that was not the phones belief about
where they were okay and the answer is
they didn't do it now you can argue that
we did all that mean you know we did all
these things right wrong or different
but they were hoping but we didn't we
think looking for that in fact the
interesting thing was we even mildly
confronted people about this right i
mean we actually had the laws we were in
interviews with people and we sort of
saying you know I have this log that
suggests it on you know this time when
you were talking about this person that
you know you didn't do that oh yeah the
phone you know the phone didn't give me
the right option or something I mean we
really tried to talk to them about these
sort of a-what few there were in fact
there was only a couple and you know
like I said it was one was this mother
who wanted to get the kit ready at home
and told a lie in the sense that she
wanted to be in the car not at the
office which is where she really was
meaning if you call that a lie that's a
sort of pretty broad definition of lie
and but it's clear that it's really
important on mobile phones people do it
all the time on mobile phones so I don't
know we just need to figure out how to
get at I'm not sure how to measure it
yeah
you've done the study I like it so what
do you think are the elements of the
location app that will actually be
successful right because we've talked
about this in like a community for a
year Charlie but in terms of does it
have widespread usage answer's no and so
I'm kind of curious to get your take of
what are the elements that will turn
this into no tool that 500 million
people use good I think there's a couple
I'll throw a couple random suggestions
out you one is the negative case you
know I don't have a glass top house if
there was a killer app for GPS I would
live in a house they had a glass top so
that i could get gps in my house but I
don't write so clearly already you could
make an argument that people are not
sort of jumping at gps apps other than
wayfinding so you I that sort of backing
up your statement I think there's a
couple of things I think the success of
dodgeball you know 1,500 people a day
admittedly in a very strange place the
island of Manhattan in fact the lower
east side that's sort of interesting
right I think they're they're onto
something people want to talk to each
other about location I think they want
to do it for socializing reasons I'm
actually not as convinced by the the
coordination stuff because i think the
coordination stuff could probably be
handled with relatively simple means
like ETA you know if the phone just
offered you an option it calculated your
route to where you were going to go and
offered you the ability to tell the
person the other end you know five
minutes ten minutes something like that
well
that's right you could have the precepts
I was actually gonna do something clever
like try to do traffic estimation and
all these kind of things but yeah you
could just have a list you know five ten
fifteen half hour one hour two hours
right that might be fine stuck in
traffic but I do believe that
socializing is really location is I like
a really key thing and I think there's
some there's a lot of stuff going on
with these apps involved with meeting up
with people and for socializing reasons
that I think may have some legs that's
the only one that I've seen a really
compelling argument for I think our
coordination stuff indicates that this
is a nice to have I think people use it
a couple times a day you'll be okay nuts
checking what happened okay to che fanno
did my family homes only hey you know
but again do you need a fancy location
after that or if you just put a
Bluetooth beacon in an electrical socket
and whatever the phone sees it it says
the kids at home right do you need a
fancy location system for that probably
not right i think that the keith ones
from that are going to be socializing
and particularly in dense areas I'm not
sure in Kansas that location is all that
relevant because Kansas is a really big
place with really few people yeah I
think you have to really think about
times when using the phone is like even
Cambrian sorry my husband oh what's okay
the question we keep asking ourselves
was could they have done this almost as
easily just with the phone so that's I
think what you have to get I think your
cynicism is well-founded know anyone are
not being cynical actually I'm just
trying to find the elements that will
actually take this advice pastry
don't ask Oh Gaming is actually another
one that I think will get subtraction I
think physical physical world gaming
that uses mobile phones will get some
traction I want to ask the opposite
question I'll done so so right so you've
now learned an awful lot about what
people want to do with their mobile
phones and what they use them for um and
maybe this isn't the right answer so
maybe you know are there other other we
thought about saying hey forget all this
place stuff even though that's you know
we're at this place lab place Oh are
they don't lab project ah maybe there's
something cool like maybe you know small
vocabulary speech recognition that
triggers an SMS message that would work
just as well i'll still be interesting
maybe you've discovered that people only
have you know ten SMS messages they want
to send and we need a better way to
shortcut those or maybe that that
interrupt ability is the key and I
should have two phone numbers you can
call me and I priority low priority yeah
you know like what are their features
like that that you think but would I
have pitched an intern project if it
tells you my interest in your first
question which is my intern project is
make me a convincing argument that if
you made this sort of shortcut for SMS
thing quick and easy that you know I
want something convincing enough that I
can go to a business person and say your
SMS traffic will go up twenty seven
point two percent if you offered the
following set of templates now I think
it says I think it's a little trickier
than just shortcuts I think you've got
to get a little bit of context right but
I don't think you need a lot I think you
need a little so yeah I think that's
interesting one in other words can you
just do SMS shortcuts I think the speech
one is interesting i actually am a
little dubious of the speech one because
it's visible to other people in your
environment and what you know i think
that people like SMS because it's
private particularly teens who don't
have as much control over their sort of
Hira balaen jazz adults do well and
frankly with the experience sampling
method we've done the reason we've done
it on Palm Pilots we did some toying
around with this early on to wonder if
we should do audio and let people speak
their responses and most people don't
want to do that because they're often
interrupted in places where it's
inappropriate to speak out loud but if
they have the ability to just kind of
you know turn to the side and fill a
questionnaire out
quietly they can't even do it in the
movie theater they can do it here well
we're in the middle of a talk and so
that ability to not speak that's that's
two of your three I'm not sure okay what
the other one was but that's two of them
yeah I believe that shortcuts are good I
think speeches a little dodgy there are
ten there are times when it would be
appropriate for one you had very
personal / be home I don't know that one
you'd be easy to measure because I think
people already do this with the caller
ID combined with the ringtones I think
they already use their there my phone
does this I hope that I rent electricity
I when I call my wife and you want an
extra bit to go through the Opera so I
want to ask her are you okay but if
she's busy you're driving or something I
don't that I don't want her to answer ah
so you want it to be kind of extra
information from your end that gets back
stuff without her interacting with it
yeah yeah I think the lack of
interaction that we saw story was not
too good I think people like the control
I think you can make sort of our games
to go back to goffman I'm gonna
reference kaufman despite the fact that
I don't really understand it I think you
can go back to sort of these ideas that
people want to manage their external
face pretty strongly i think there's you
have to do that really well because i
think the interesting thing is people
want to express things to other people
about the way they respond example is
people who sit on email this classic
people who sit on email because I've
written the response they save it as a
draft they wait till tomorrow and then
they send it why do they do that because
they don't want the other person to
think they're at their disposal we also
had people in the initial study send
request denied a lot when they thought a
request was inappropriate as opposed to
answering with something like I am busy
yeah so I think that one is one that
interaction i think you you can make an
argument that's a good thing because of
cars and driving is for safety but i
think it's you've got to do that really
well encourage you guys to look abroad
like i moved to india in october and the
cell phone usage there is radically
different than it is here like I
exchange SMS messages with every person
i work with
I mean a very casual so that's two like
when the plumber the electrician comes
over the SMS is used to give in my
address and the mobile phone number is
exchanged with literally almost every
person that I'm interact wit and it's
what's interesting is the mobile phone
has revolutionized the business for
people who are providing services to
other people right because all of a
sudden they're reachable and you can
call them and they can call you and and
the actual volume that say a taxi cab
driver or delivery guy can now do who's
making like 90 bucks a month right he's
gone up by huge amounts and so I
actually think these location services
in a business context especially those
hooks are really interested out where
we're highly aware of that and you know
when you're a really big company that
has a huge market share one of the ways
you get bigger is binding places that
you can sell stuff to people who don't
already have your stuff so yeah so this
is sort of why Genevieve Bella's doing
inside Asia for us sort of urban Asia
projects and stuff like that but yeah
and in fact we've had some volunteers
from Finland also who's wanted to repeat
our studies with finish families and
kids are there issued mobile phones at
birth so you know there's a lot of
belief that the families treat mobile
phones in a very different way than we
do in the u.s. in fact just SMS usage in
the u.s. is basically five years behind
Europe as a general approximation so
yeah I think that's a good idea and I'd
love a reason to go to to Thailand or to
India I think that'd be great I think
that think is worth doing too and I
think we one of the things is people are
a lot more phone centric there in these
places and Genevieve build results not
mine you know people are very think of
the cell phone in a very different way
it sort of is their computational device
they don't sort of associate that as
much with PCs at least from Intel
standpoint so the idea that they want
sort of new stuff on their phones
downloadable stuff is not alien to them
that's a cool thing that's standard in a
look at Korea where ringtone markets are
you know billions of billions of dollars
right so the idea that there are places
where for example just getting new stuff
for your phone is going to be a much
more acceptable thing I think is those
places are good and I think you're up at
least better than here unfortunately I
live in Seattle so can only do so much
Oh which is I went to a wedding this is
a very funny story and there was a guy
at the wedding just kept getting
Bluetooth viruses that kind of tried to
install themselves on the phone right so
in terms of downloading stuff there's
the negative side yeah it's almost
there's danger and going to public
places now if you've turned on bluetooth
and have a nokia phone because it'll
just get infected by all these people
around you're trying to install the
application that's that's i wish i had
that problem it would be that'll be so
cool to have like more stuff on my
phones so we have big piles with those
Nokia's so anyway I should probably wrap
it up I want to make sure that people
don't get shortchanged